before we get started I want to be clear
about what we're not going to teach you
in this course we're not going to be
teaching mobile frameworks like
bootstrap or native app wrappers like
PhoneGap these are great tools but we
want to teach the fundamentals that you
as a mobile web developer need to know
first
many of our coding examples are centered
around a single conference application
which we've put in a github repository
not every concept fits well in that app
so we'll be using other examples - we're
going to begin with a lesson on mobile
development tools showing you how to
hook up the dev tools to your mobile
browser if you already know how to do
this feel free to skip this section
let's get started